we're the only species that does some
[ __ ] like that
what [ __ ] I hate them to feel sorry for
us what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of hot box and I'm Evan
Britt and I'm Mike Tyson Mike we got we
got a little cross podcast pollination
going down button and we've got his
sidekicks Rory and mom I didn't know you
had a podcast watching you on a hip-hop
show and one time I guess somebody stuff
you and your girl awesome she got your
back dog unless she still got she still
gonna on his back some of those rules
about you know I had approached I had
approached two gentlemen a good guy - I
don't want this good guy and now all
that is in the past water under the
bridge but I approached the gentleman
about some things he was saying during
promo at promo like I showed up to a
radio station that he was there I didn't
assume consequences yeah he's a Tribune
he had the white girl right yeah that
was a trip too
yes I asked him about some things he
said I guess he didn't like it and you
know you did what you had to do I will
be in that show about like 15 years
younger 20 years I would be on that show
[ __ ] rage ain't nobody stood the
ratings will be through the roof with my
cup oh my god I'm watching I agree I'm
watching yeah we watch there's me my
wife could we know some of the people in
the show maybe no people everyone the
show that's what makes it fun and listen
anybody that be saying [ __ ] that
[ __ ] and back at a [ __ ] big man I
wish I was on that show well we got
drinks we got weed
we got some good dudes in here ready to
[ __ ] have sticking with your one
[ __ ] neck and girlie show that other
ones on the side you see that take it
take some will I know you're [ __ ]
alcohol you a sex addict - so how did
you know what's funny about that Mike I
don't think I'm a sex addict
the show shows that your sex addict you
have an open to you you'll know the
women in the newest and the newest
season it shows quite the opposite of
show who are you don't I ain't doing a
whole lot of [ __ ] night no more right
you're not no more
I did it at one point that's how know
like very aware how much [ __ ] [ __ ]
do you want to be flies even [ __ ] the
parable [ __ ] you that they will comes
with their mother [ __ ] all praise be
savage stop couldn't stop I had to go to
the hospital for what the doctors
couldn't stop that's kind of you yeah
commitment issues I just don't commit
quickly that's an issue yeah with Ken we
all know the definition of the concept
that I 100 matter the Qaeda never knew
the concept the concept that that should
tell this go around being married does
he saw relationships to get this peep
death this is my woman my wife I come
here my wife right hmm now what would
make me think this any state any country
I go to like I run through in law why
would I stop all that for her hmm what
does she do to make me stop all that for
her she don't you don't [ __ ] better than
that last [ __ ] I [ __ ] in Belgium mmm
why did I stop well fo yeah and Belgium
has great waffle United me [ __ ] in what
is it what do you come
- and Master summers to improve myself
oh yeah better person mm-hmm yeah you
know that's our comes down with the
earth I want to improve myself I want to
be better well when's the last time
you've been to Belgium no the UM that's
just the way the world is you have to be
in have a urge to improve yourself to
believe that there are something better
than me [ __ ] this [ __ ] I [ __ ] a
hundred time I know what the feeling I'm
gonna get after I do this I want to I
want to do something that I don't know
the after-effects of it mm-hmm I want to
be surprised about something and that's
growth and maturity and yeah yeah
searching I don't know if it's growth to
meet Rita better search I don't want
this no more I don't want this no more
then that's life got me with jail bad
[ __ ] in the paper
North suits my diseases babies that [ __ ]
in the head
mm-hmm you know that's what that life
got me look at all the [ __ ] women bring
women don't bring them you know I mean
because I'm the conception I have of
myself Porter my illusion of myself for
it all that [ __ ] to me well what was
that illusion excuse me what was that
illusion there's what God hmm yeah how
could they be better than me I did I did
look good look at me I came from
Brownsville could I come from
Brownsville be right here and I have to
be the highest-paid [ __ ] the
Flies [ __ ] be youngest [ __ ] do all
this [ __ ] and you know I mean that's it
when it comes down to it it's all a
[ __ ] illusion 100 persuade this is
all an illusion this is my ego this is
my shame my guilt my jealousy my in
Venus what age you start realizing her
yesterday oh my [ __ ] he goes [ __ ]
talking [ __ ] man the planet [ __ ]
comes scared somebody beat me up before
robbed me before took my money I was a
kid so now I'm and I'm a bad [ __ ] the
way better [ __ ] with me again that kind
of [ __ ] it work secure [ __ ]
nobody didn't
because now I gotta change everything
that believe that made me this person I
developed a bee I figured with a [ __ ]
line so that I got read I gotta figure
out who I really am
but don't we have to continuously do
that absolutely never it's an L yeah
yeah it never stops
yeah never ends definitely I feel like
my tyson should be a therapist
no Mike Tyson needs therapy constantly
that's those are the people huh
yeah a therapist yeah yeah you go how
often you go I see him every [ __ ] day
in my dreams really yeah
this is like therapy in here yeah me for
sure yeah
I've had so many dudes hit me up being
like thank you guys so much for the
conversations you have I'm just like so
angry I'm so tired I'm so [ __ ] you
know the podcast you guys had the other
day brought me to tears you know because
it's just like we're going to [ __ ] that
you know we're cutting to the core of
what makes us us fear makes us and never
get too hungry angry lonely or tired
yeah that's real that's the material
it's interesting that two guys for me
what it is with two guys that come from
such brutal sports can be such calm and
like soft people like y'all are very
like loving and passionate you have to
be beating a submission yeah Venus
mission brother you don't give that you
don't get the ego up the egos not the
ego that's this you don't say oh I mean
use all that ego I'm bad they're gonna
pound Padma [ __ ] and then I get
everything the eagle I want to get
summoned out and then I say hey I see
you later bye it doesn't work like that
mm-hm no I wanna hang around wanna [ __ ]
that girl - I want you to do this I want
you to do this now - doesn't go away
what to control you you know what I
heard the other day was no one will ever
know the violence it took to become this
gentle Wow yes yeah you know that's that
feels like my life and I know that's
Mike's life you know but yeah man it's
all about continuously evolving and
shifting and just being open to that you
know not getting stuck in one place if
this is who I am this is what I do you
know this is what I believe even my
because it changes all the time it's
like Joe I mean you've I mean you've
totally transitioned your life and who
you are and what you do I mean maybe not
the core of you that pearl essence that
is Joe Budden but you know who you are
and what you do is way different than it
was 20 years ago probably 100% but I get
bored easily too as a creator yeah so I
cost I have to continue to feed whatever
creative juices are inside of me so like
everybody was really shocked when I said
never happened no more mm-hmm but beside
besides from besides looking at what it
did for me how it changed perception how
other people viewed me if the box that
they took me out of because I was no
longer rapping you know I was able to I
was able to have conversations that I
probably wouldn't have been able to have
before with some people I was able to
maybe close some deals or with doors
that would have been closed to me as a
rapper just a lot you never know what's
on it I got stigmas rappers do have
sticks are stigmatized and and much
deeper than that
we're we're black so you always have to
battle that that battle never leaves so
you know my mom raised me I want to take
it as many of the stigmas away as
possible
oh I don't want it to a buncha [ __ ]
just believe in a whole bunch [ __ ] about
me that's not true what's important for
my words my actions to match and just
the hip-hop that raised me to hip-hop I
know the heat comes from it's different
today man
but it's I got a kid this 18 you know
huh it's not it's my my energy is my
time my focus I've spent enough time on
me like the selfishness and that's where
rap was I needed to stay alive I need to
defend it why what never the richest
[ __ ] ever but the time that you miss
from your family the holidays just
missing your kid grow up it's just like
kind of like what Mike was saying
earlier that constant evolution like the
timing of you combined with the timing
of where the universe is and what you
will learn from that you know man
yeah I don't want to get it too talking
too deep in here but else we got wood so
how did you guys all meet because you
guys are awesome you're great team the
podcast is off the [ __ ] channel yeah
thank you you guys are killing it I want
to talk about the live shows cuz these
guys we're getting ready to do a little
hotbox in life [ __ ] location is [ __ ]
- yeah we love it invite don't just tell
that you guys are definitely I'd love to
come so how did you guys all meet how
did this come together well I met Joe
years ago through a mutual friend and um
but I had we had like I had seen Joe and
Def Jam being that my family worked at
Def Jam at the time so I would see Joe
in passing but we'd never really hung
out and like was friends and then years
later we met through a mutual friend and
our relationship Connor just grew from
there and we lived together for for a
few years and yeah it's just like you
know just the relationship we have as
friends as friends it's awesome Rory I
met Joe in 2012 or 2013 working on a
video for him and then we just kind of
became cool and kicked it from there
wasn't really an intricate story so I
really awkward - yeah when I hear how
men French
had the same sarcasm and music it's like
[Music]
on the show I think people have dry
humor immediately identify with someone
else that has one and hit it off because
it takes a different type of brain to
really appreciate drying we're yeah me
and Joe was just like polar opposites so
I think that's why our relationship
works a lot of [ __ ] he's not doing
any [ __ ] no more underst under states
under states this book for many many
years
mall has been the person to keep me calm
hmm
that I'm often it but that's because
we're polar opposites like I operate
from this type of energy and he's over
here I'm just like I used to make you
very much erratic impulsive decisions
that would harm no one but me yeah why
do we do it the only species that does
some [ __ ] like that what [ __ ] it is
their [ __ ] I hate them and one feel
sorry for us
you're absolutely right yeah right now
for love crying for love yeah
then we played it with flour you Harper
that's what we are 1 for my love is so
bad we don't know we want to kill
ourselves right yeah yeah oh damn
it's crazy when you put it that way [ __ ]
yeah or just attention sometimes it's
not even love let me just
I just need attention if the perception
of the [ __ ] know do I think I am out
that one [ __ ] to see me even in
this show [ __ ] wanna hear the
farmer uneducated [ __ ] talk with you
know me stable [ __ ] diction what I
want [ __ ] laughing a [ __ ] one
listen to me why I got all these [ __ ]
you know what's this [ __ ] that you got
none of the people listening to positive
you know me a [ __ ] ninth grader [ __ ]
I know I think that's what it is all my
that your story is just so intriguing
and interesting to people that they just
have to they just want to talk to you
and wonder if just pick your brain no
it's not that [ __ ] deep down you in
my ego to tell me a [ __ ] flying
[ __ ] need to hear me I need to shut my
[ __ ] yeah you do definitely yeah I
think most of my like my all my success
is based off my ego my low self-esteem
but my megalomania of think that thought
that I have of myself but these days
these days you walk around thinking
[ __ ] have to hear me
no no I tell myself shut the [ __ ] up
yeah me too a lot yeah shut the [ __ ] up
but still I can't help it listen to me I
can talk to I came to work today
right you know you think it happens
overnight you know me it feels their own
something look I got you this she's dumb
[ __ ] I got you the chappie
I got you this now you don't know you've
been talking to some other [ __ ]
for two hours you don't want it to be
down with me no more look what I did all
your life right I sent you to prison
to donate but you know we all feel that
energy that we can't explain it allowing
us to listen to what I'm saying right
now and I'm making my opinion than I
mind before we even say anything right
you know how come we can't describe that
maybe some of us do you feel like this
is therapy for you like having a show
[ __ ] them no no no no I just like the
show right the show is should I get
accustomed to it right I like the show
and I like some time to get mad after
you guys we got a [ __ ] um IX Mafia and
four informant coming in here this is
going to be pretty interesting yeah but
Mike Tyson will be a table will be
paying attention yeah so Joe what is it
that you want when this is basically
almost over 375 so what do you want what
is what do you want how do you want to
finish this [ __ ] gig if I get to 75
yes when it's over I was I would look at
God and say boy while you did that and
as I never pictured that I never
pictured out I never looked at that
before I will I always put it put the
benchmark at it like at 15 I saw it I
saw it 21 being in at 21 I saw it I had
the same [ __ ] 30th might not come
living like that - that's why I can't
believe I'm [ __ ] man catchy hey
there's no [ __ ] diseases and all that
[ __ ] stored it some serious [ __ ]
right now
and so this devil to kill myself I said
let me try to live right yeah yeah yeah
this what can I try I tried everything
yes didn't work
let me see it's gonna work I mean how
many of the fighters today do you like
me how many of the fighters today do you
men so on talk to I don't talk today but
I say my house I leave my job and I go
home sound like me yeah I don't go
nowhere I eat sometimes I'm I don't know
I get that sometimes I don't trust
myself yeah you know I take my home yeah
let me know I trust myself in here trust
myself my you know though with demons
hmm oh go for it dude yes well on that
note of the boxers thing we've been
having we've had some of those guys come
in here now and it's really interesting
to see them with Mike hmm and you know
just the wisdom that my chasm and in
this new version of Mike to see him like
we went and talked to the University of
Alabama Mike you talked to the football
team before this is what the University
of these people believe they really uh I
don't really wanna really wanna do they
know what they have on their hands do
they think there's kids waiting for a
chance I'm gonna take these kids there
these kids have been adapted to a
certain lifestyle weight living their
life well they miss cheevus they're
gonna get in some [ __ ] yes he believes
if he takes these kids and he put them
away keep away isolate them yeah I took
training to prepare money let them out
for the game and so in the game and the
season is over I don't care what you do
no more not that [ __ ] animal they're
gonna go out there and go crazy you know
it's like it's just like a conquering
army to conquer the city or country nice
hey your day is over now they're going
out there you know it's all about
preparing people for life kids for life
is my opinion but the prepare them with
financial advisors they're not
interested in that are interested in
winning football I know but you have to
have class my ability to be in a
football team
absolutely but you still come out of
there [ __ ] up because you're in that
[ __ ] prism of being a football player
like it's like me and I'm prison so when
come out of football they have to be
dirt they have to meet their Derby that
yeah yeah we'll be done become you going
to the Spartan camp for four years may
you play for five years and now you come
on Hank buy that was wonderful game
thank you but you still you still
competitive you still got hungry you
still you still bipolar that's why all
the musicians are [ __ ] up exactly what
you just said hmm same same same thing
with the labels and care about you in
this album time care about you in the
show Tom care about you all the time
some countries the government is a
lifetime thing after you go to school we
pick head of school we take education
take care of houses but we're taking
care of kids now we're taking cake me
show you um your social security but
it's a lifetime thing you're [ __ ]
with this country you know you know I
mean and this in the country like
America hey every man for themself is a
woman for themselves scratch to the top
crawl to the top it's a rat race and
even though you win you're still a
[ __ ] rat 1000 yeah you know yeah we
gotta talk like that about a miracle
non-pom time the world the best the best
people come out of this country know why
because we have without us knowing we
have to leave the ship secrets of all
the greatest warriors they never lived
on this planet cuz that's how we live we
put the it's like Alexander the Great
just like arm I tell her that on all
those guys we take all the young kids
and we put them against each other have
him compete the brothers the sister
haven't compete and whoever gets to the
top if the King the best let me focus on
him hmm
that's just how it is all said it's a
group of people we focus on this group
that's how we work in this country
if he's shining they come you know he's
shining this focalin let's put some more
energy on him let's put some more water
I love having to grow they feed him some
more interest he's just he just comes
with a spark let's feed them to a spark
to become the fire let's be feed that
fire that becomes the roaring [ __ ]
blaze and that's how the stars are born
yeah
but they need help they need grown men
yeah
Roselle Dan Lee being competition it's
like battling caught they have to be in
competition you have to know who's the
best well your talk was the ultimate
[ __ ] eye opener for those kids you
know I mean one of the things Mike said
is all you guys you see that because
they played this badass highlight reel
of them all Mike's knockouts and and you
know Mike's like you see that guy up
there that dude that you think you know
or who you think I am that Iron Mike guy
I don't like that guy I'm not that guy
anymore and it was like you get here
[ __ ] pin drop in there you know I
don't know what they were expecting yeah
that's what I think that's what it is
people have a perception of Mike because
you're watching them and seeing
everything that he's done everything
that he's been through so if somebody
would just always fixated on yeah so
then when you see him everything that
you thought he was so that's what I'm
going through right now like everything
I thought Mike was and I mean I've been
watching over the years as his change
but it's still hearing certain things
I'm like you thought you felt like that
back then I remembered what it was to
sit down and order pay-per-view to watch
a fight and the whole family beat it
yeah and the image I had him is this is
the baddest dude on the [ __ ] planet
walking into the ring it was just of
yeah the Anteaters
sort of hear him say in that moment it
was just scared yeah it was [ __ ] me
mind-blowing like cuz I know what it did
I felt like the baddest [ __ ] in
the planet watching you come out and
fight 100 reserved so you to say in that
moment tell me that you were scared [ __ ]
me up yeah I don't know why bomb if I
never felt scared I would never fight
that bit mode of it and motivates me
it's like fuel for [ __ ] successes if
I don't have it it's um it's fear but
everything in my [ __ ] sight has to
[ __ ] die it's just feeling it feeling
like an intergalactic juggernaut hmm
yeah but they executed yeah like that's
like that's why these these type of
platforms I think are so important it
adds context and understanding to a
perception they may have had of you from
just walking out to a boxing ring where
you have to be in a completely different
mind state to operate there these
platforms are the most important and
that's not being stated enough
these are the platforms that are gonna
explain the world to the world they
won't think I killed my pigeon I turned
into a monster that's what happened
that's my old life started come back do
my [ __ ] pigeon
I don't play over pitch though you guys
know that story no yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah definitely yeah and then I met
these [ __ ] guys that were like back
I'm they took all the money may kill
this [ __ ] the seat up snatched change
dick pocket breaking out then I met
those guys cuz I fought back with it and
I killed my bird that made my whole
[ __ ] life changed then I became the
bully the [ __ ] criminal or the bad
guy hmm
it all started yeah so it all started
mmm well I saw me fight back well dad
this has been a life lesson for me this
just this this sit down and that's why
podcast so important cuz I would I just
talking out there I can't believe that a
podcast is what got me in front of you
no I'm saying it's still like crazy to
me but that's why these platforms are
important yeah awesome I did the fact I
thought the [ __ ] that was a mofo gonna
make fun of my [ __ ] Melissa [ __ ] got
a million people viewing this [ __ ] with
the [ __ ] my fan I had for my one tip
in right yeah listen what we want to
talk to you about son what do you think
about deaf brother before the [ __ ] gets
over what do we only have you what do I
think about death we're no you no longer
exist in this physical world here we go
yes death is death in the physical I got
fascinated so I talk about death a lot
too um why do you talk about it you fear
you're curious something I don't figured
oh yeah I don't fear you can't talk
about it after it happens that's why I
talk about no we all know I think it's
just part of the process as you think
can no longer exist nothing no matter
for a blink of an eye no
we are here I think when it's over I'm
floating up to wherever the next chapter
is mmm hey tell him about us stuff that
that I take every down there the toad
yeah if I wasn't that the toad what's
that what's that old you guys live in
New York yeah I love Jordan your vein
today yes yeah yeah it's closer now
longer yes Bulger no of course that's
important yeah the toad is a mystical
creature found in the Sonoran Desert and
they utilize it for its venom and they
extract its venom and they dry it out
and it becomes this five Meo DMT you
guys have heard of DMT
so five visio DMT is like the next level
of an eat oh yeah diem together it's got
an extra methyl oxy group on it so it
travels faster to your brain so you can
vaporize it in a ceremony and you have
an experience of God an ego death you
you know feel the oneness of everything
people honest am drinking my stab you
can smoke to tell depression anxiety you
know it cures all sorts of mental and
you know maybe physical ailments as well
and Mike has done it a few times he
sounds excited yeah kind of but it's
really worth it though I'm sure what is
the experience when you want it 15
Detroit laughs for the rest of your life
well you feel that it lands you when you
woke up you thought you asleep for
10,000 years
Wow I think you think you'd never oh we
should have listened
you're gonna find it in the toad the
toad is not kind of doing you can do and
we can talk yeah toad you going out so
leaving your body oh you're gonna have
an experience with God
yeah so DRT yeah I've heard of DMC
actually would drive in say more telling
me about it that's it the same thing get
where that I'd give it to me that they
don't get and when I had that Oh myself
inside behind [ __ ] I tried to prove
somewhat that try pony [ __ ] white
boys killed me they killed me I'm dead
that's just what I said
trying to prove things I couldn't
explain nobody could believe me because
I didn't believe myself I said let's do
it again
I can't believe what I just experienced
the same things I'm able to I'm
breathing like a hand look no something
different yeah so now so now did they
provide the tote or did they tell you
weird no the shaman right and he's
talking all this [ __ ] that this told us
this it a tree makes you mean it's the
guard monocle you can make garden
everybody says shut the [ __ ] up let me
see it shut the [ __ ] away that bird it's
a real Bobby didn't did I said whoa it
humbled me it looks and everything that
you think you had with the secret that's
madness everything you see this is think
you have a secret and you know what
nobody didn't know you serving your mind
they notice the pain they have on you
now we're totally go to other [ __ ]
direction all of our secrets that we may
have also you smoke this you have the
feeling that everyone in the world knows
it now imagine you feeling that man is
feeling the seeker you don't want nobody
ever no matter what it is he said oh
[ __ ] they all know
I don't know if I want that feel you you
learn the Caesar release never know who
we really are sometimes we don't like
him then we find hey that's all right
right no we have to find out who we are
before we leave this for a bit we have
to get in touch with this mmm yeah we
can get in touch with that that's wasted
life just waste it
yeah that's intense have you done it
I've done
DMT I haven't done eternity DMT the
beautiful that's fun it's like a like I
said like ten thousand years of
experience coming at you fast feel
evidence in your life go way back to a
little baby I you know you want to share
it it's over
yeah it's just everywhere I go like you
know anywhere in the world we just came
back from Poland catalyst an old and I
got one people come up to me for hey
congratulations I just tried to toe -
congratulations on your experience mmm
okay sounds like that yet people that
try to you be in a family your brother
gotcha gotcha your brother got you okay
I think I can't can't even bring it all
back of the hood
you have anybody start talking about
life and dying and after death the end
of the world what's my [ __ ] purpose
he really get the [ __ ] rap afraid
that my purpose don't feel like my
purpose yeah you know what can I shut up
why am I thinking about me why I little
about me everything I'm [ __ ] think of
this about me
Wendy shut the [ __ ] about with that
[ __ ] foul let's go to [ __ ] away you
get tired hearing about yourself you
know it'd be so many weeks where I said
you know I'm so [ __ ] tired of hearing
my [ __ ] voice I can't cuz y'all got
to hear my voice
but I'm sick of it I be needing
sabbaticals I'll be needing yeah [ __ ]
that's what it is some guys gonna better
take man I think that's what it is
you gotta meditate [ __ ] yeah share to
toe with white boys when they give you
know they're gonna be your mentor you be
like Maharaja you know it's just some
ism enlightenment you know I came in
this business looking for money and
wealth and [ __ ] I needed money cuz
that's all I thought was life was about
getting money getting bit to get my man
choose my place but looking man somebody
has succeeded and it all comes down that
realize it's all about giving it away
let it go getting out of your [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] then only for you to knock yo
the [ __ ] you think you I mean get on
your [ __ ] knees it's such a tough
realization I have quite a few people in
my life
weird you know they come to me for
advice and my advice is you know we
don't matter no man you are so life no
man is so insignificant
we say that you know everything and that
when you realize the line should get on
your knees and pray all got a full so I
please have my send myself yes I'm sorry
I did that to that girl I'm sorry oh
[ __ ] I'm sorry
anytime man oh [ __ ] you the off [ __ ]
when I have a hard time with that I just
look up at the sky I might I did I just
look I look up at the moon or the Sun
the end like this is what the [ __ ] we
down here doing place in Nepal
I mean told somebody before with a bunch
of Buddhist monks live right and they
all keep a skull in their bedroom just
realized this is what life's about it's
a joke
cuz even when you always see ask us
ahead of us colors always appears to be
smiling or laughing life with the joke
how serious we took [ __ ] no lost I here
called Harley tax court diseases how cuz
man we are but but to your point earlier
to get to get to this level of sad
called spirituality you gotta go you
gotta go you got to go through it I say
all the time I'm either coming out of
some going through some or about to go
through something the end good stuff no
good exciting goddamn dance it's gotta
say there's always there's always [ __ ]
goin down you know life has always
happened but can you matter where like
it's life is so exciting here man you a
death it's gonna be like mmm life does
not be glory bliss the kids gonna be
[ __ ] I think like I always tell me I
believe our dreams and our death is life
is a birth in our death our dreams and
our life is go on forever
mmm you know awesome and I realized I
hate living that really I'm so awesome
lived at this particular time I
[ __ ] Michael Jordan Ulis [ __ ]
will arrive is I've met Sammy David but
frankly I met all these guys before they
all died in this stuff yeah time to live
I've already played that entire scene
out imma be in the sky flying away from
you [ __ ] I think it's gonna be just
like me down here I don't think so big I
believe you all been a different life
before it'll be a different life we say
five we don't even know how old the
world is we don't know we invented car
yeah
fukiko nothing you know nothing about
life there's no rumors of life in the
history of life only did the rumors yeah
we know all the [ __ ] that they put
in the books and taught us in school or
attempted to we I didn't I didn't know I
would have to unlearn in every you look
at rappers fighters and stuff but we're
greater than [ __ ] Roman generals we
created an Alexander the Great with
greater than all those great generals
that ever live all those masters all
those dis spots all those great monsters
or leaders good we're greater than all
that and we're seeing what they can
never see and that's the future right
and that's another big big huge reason
that I just I can't I can't fear death
but I feel like I can see the future
that's gonna sound nuts and I won't say
it nowhere so I'll tell it to you yeah I
think that's I think that's a mistake to
the fear death I really think that's a
mistake I think that's almost gonna be
like I said huh you're gonna realize
this is such a this is when we live this
is when we wake up one need eyes will be
wake up and you shouldn't fear something
that's supposed to have it supposed to
happen today was supposed to happen is
that's our ego that with egos telling us
that we gonna how can I die I'm gonna
have to go live in the next dimension
yes is you go to think you guys control
the interim
down here things I have control I never
lose control until I lose control
you know what the [ __ ] we'll have
control for anyway
every time I had control our loss but I
want to have control for I need the
mouth to guide me cook me lead in my
life yeah you know roar he touching your
soul right now you don't want top 50
rappers Liz yes yeah I said is that
really your picks yeah yeah Frenchy's
hey no listen now check it out right
y'all talk about like 15 20 years ago
rat with a imagine when the first start
when you first start out like what I say
1979 1980 mmm and we're looking at which
we did on my breath it's the building
somebody got that I'm like the Latin
quarters or something wrapping it
somebody's in there rap and say Melly
Mel's in there rapping the flashes and
they're rapping at the time right it's
packed
everybody is the cops outside away it's
like a man it's like a [ __ ] crime
scene mmm if you was associated with
that you were bad people even the black
community associate with that [ __ ]
hip-hop [ __ ] [ __ ] you're [ __ ] crazy
mm-hmm I should've whacked that [ __ ] for
bad people mm-hmm that's a distinct what
it was just all for bad [ __ ]
good people didn't associate with
hip-hop mmm back then and now it's the
biggest no absolutely I used to go to
all the kind I went to all the Run DMC
concerts they were going all over
Houdini act hang out with them when they
went to England went to the concert when
they were performing out there I did all
those cars back in there
LL Cool J let me see this Fresh Prince
Will Smith Will Smith did a song about
me when he was a little kid city really
yeah
mmm all those that many was it but the
juice crew dates to be with the juice
screw with bit with Biz Markie and all
those guys so I see Joe you looking for
your name on the list
no but the people that speak like my I'm
not on the list I should be but the
people that people that talk like Mike
like with this hip-hop [ __ ] they all
have Treach hi them only when I get
around young people or them
oh yes like no I have treasure but up
he's a man man
yeah Mike why didn't you put Treach any
breweries in group huh treach's in a
group he's a naughty by nature now but
the [ __ ] way but the group was
nothing without them well if there's no
him there's no group yeah you guys sound
so feels like so diverse the crack so
you know the group is on its back so
it's really like Treach hmm no but it
was great you too yeah he's the writer
here listen this is this is interesting
too this is not really good this is this
is the ego crusher to way I could write
these songs for everybody that's a right
through all but only this guy makes it
magic hmm everybody up there give me
they give me a fright they give me gold
and stuff they give me platinum ISM but
this guy makes me magic mm-hmm why was
there enough for everybody else and
they're good to go I doesn't give a
magic like this guy because he's touched
he's special
you know I didn't put big as number one
I put the mouth then somebody else put
them in order
oh just like fighting I can never say
who's the best ever all the time and
it's really hard it's one guy that could
listen JD could be doing my 20 year
running nothing but hits right and then
one guy who only had one hit and it
could dominate anything hmm the whole 20
years or something that's how it
happened that's how fighting is well
what guys will be having rain for 100
years if one guys can last for one year
but having one excited year makes you
never forget who he was you know he's
like a burning comet that one that
little moment is making lasts forever
mm-hmm yeah there's people that I don't
even know why they exist like that they
don't even care about themselves they
don't care they look but they cut
there's magic when they do whatever they
do singing and dancing rapping whatever
it is
run himself hack then whatever it is
that you can't probably can't wait to
see them the next time yeah my giver we
did our top 10 fighters list oh yeah I
think about all the time who's the
greatest fighter never say foo [ __ ] you
know I mean right so you guys think
about the one that sometimes you look at
me look at Matt especially at Wu stay
Pernell Whitaker we have lost him he's
[ __ ] absolutely insane right Amy did
drunk and he beat the best fighter in
the world at the little kitty without
now he's drunk and he just beat the [ __ ]
out of a little kid with a great fighter
mmm it's a man it's winning Olympic
World Championships Pan Am Games Olympic
titles and sometimes just drinking
beating all these there's only eighteen
seventeen years old beating all these
guys it's different beating everybody
you know one see that is so big is
beating about the kid beating everybody
twice a day if I beat everybody
no one can touch him Russia and cube and
Poland will you tell you to anywhere in
the planet beating them all hmm so it's
off you just always pick a number one
absolutely absolutely day today baby
yeah just um you take a guy like this
take Sugar Ray Robinson here's what he
fights right Michael took my 40 fights
right didn't first take him on he lose
he beat you come on the first fret
second fret fight Jake come on take him
on beat him right so he had he's 40 and
40 and one now right
he after that he goes 85 and oh maybe
man you know there's some people beat up
I'm the greatest fighter in the world
you know all these pecs do the foot all
right you did fit to let me see you go
85 90 in a row
yeah but there's no way within a what a
five-year period four year period so my
four year three years for us mmm what he
for worthy for 27 years ago 55 for Ray
Robinson for 26 years right he had 200
was it
208 fights put that in perspective - how
are you gonna fight I for 15 times in
one year how often you gonna fight
that's how you that's how you that's how
you sometimes you hear like a rap I
don't know what they did a some thing I
might start [ __ ] doing that [ __ ]
riffing thing and that's like I'm
fighter come on bring it on I'll fight
you today tomorrow next week next
Tuesday I fight you in your [ __ ]
living room with your family that
officials more you do it the more you
want it how do you feel about Floyd
though how do you feel awesome fight a
great fighter you know he he's a little
too into himself you know he should be I
was the same way too but you have to
come to reality some way you have to
bring your head down the guard we know
we're nothing to be [ __ ] a grenade
will you expect us to be ignorant and
arrogant look where we came from
that's why I asked the question earlier
about you mention our fighters because I
feel like I feel like Floyd looked at
you growing up like every other fighter
and the persona and the lifestyle was
like growing up in the hood we looked at
it like that's Mike Tyson we see the
cause of jewelry that the the flare like
you was a movie star you see that I
didn't see right so that's why I'm
saying you know Floyd is going through
that and you can see it and I feel like
you're like a mirror for him and you
have you can tell them what it's gonna
be
on the other end of that means nothing I
mean it means nothing to tell somebody
that he got a feel like I didn't know
it's higher you can't tell listen I'm a
little [ __ ] mind we're doing it I
know I'm Mike baby's [ __ ] mind you
know who might think my folks you think
I'm a bad thing on the planet who -
[ __ ] to think that I'm I deserved for
some [ __ ] to praise me I think
I'm somebody great with my darkness why
do I deserve why don't I deserve to get
us my knees and kiss somebody else's ass
else to help somebody else that need to
be helped why want to hold all my money
why not give to somebody they need it
they need it more than me [ __ ] champ
I'm Mike Tyson when I'm broke I'm
special
these [ __ ] mm-hmm that's just
what it was I thought when I was broke I
was finished
nobody's gonna be around me no I'm not
gonna get
more [ __ ] I know every respect we
don't wanna left I had the more I got
more take me I [ __ ] us then I realized
it wasn't nothing wasn't the money it
was me choosen two people in the world I
strayed all the time those that are
humble and those that are about to be
and and that's a life lesson
oh no we met people people especially
that men men and I meant to be on mobile
they meant to be humbled hmm humans are
meant to be humbled and I'm not gonna be
born humbly crazy well yeah why the [ __ ]
I gotta be humble
[ __ ] [ __ ] anything [ __ ] sneaky
like to tell you sometimes that's tough
up - back to your question while I was
talking about this foot off in terms of
rappers though it's just sometimes it's
tough that's a tough lesson to learn for
really wealthy people yeah it just takes
some time yeah yeah especially if is
thinking about Floyd you know he
probably has more money than he knows
what to do with mm-hmm and he's not
trying to kill himself with drugs or
whatever it else at least from the
outside view right so then what is it
that it's gonna lead a guy like that to
an awakening you know I don't know
nobody know who the [ __ ] of one
perception
no no but you know or that people need
to have an awakening another camping
stuff I was lonely all those people
around me I was lonely man that's what
I'm about to say Evan used you said he
lives a drug-free life but there's so
many more drugs to draw yeah yeah
absolutely
yeah the attention I'm watching that
that's the number one drug right right
now right yeah yeah yeah yeah the
weighted mics that he used to view money
some of these people you know without
that attention and you just left with
you now
I never wanted me so shallow I wanted
somebody to tell me I was somebody you
know how a [ __ ] give a girl a [ __ ] a
band anything she told me I was the
greatest hmm I needed [ __ ] security I
was nothing I was a nobody that one to
be a
my tea give me give you all my money
tell me I'm great
tell my ticket the biggest mmm yeah you
know you're [ __ ] you never know how
you gonna respond you don't know who you
are until you get there yeah why do I
have this money I ain't [ __ ] my mother
ain't [ __ ] my father
I don't know why I never knew anybody
was [ __ ] where I got this [ __ ] mm-hmm no
filming
how do you understand that Joe how come
you're rapping and none of the boys are
rapping from the block they tried to rap
no no no why I never sit why's it that
way why are you rapping but then I
rapping though they tried to represent
the rapping even though you laugh but
then I wrap up your children still rap
you can still rap our company my rapping
we wish sometimes we ashamed this is
what we received of we ashamed to say
there I'm the chosen one
while I was just about to answer you and
say God God is just an really great hear
me my takes for you to get that to say
that yeah you know I was out there I was
out there we all so afraid to say God
chose me I was the chosen one I don't
want to drop my best to [ __ ] it up yeah
I don't want the same I don't want this
[ __ ] I don't want people come with me I
don't know you know hey what's up take
it I'm used to come people come they
come up it's gonna stick you up as I'm
paralyzed for autographs pulling out
guns on people affecting for what you
guys want a picture I'm an animal I
don't know how to handle this [ __ ] how
do you deal with Los Angeles I did that
before too and the eight is my first got
married I did the Los Angeles thing
that's why I wasn't mad didn't stay
married wrong even in that Mike you
gotta get to the point where you hurting
someone that you love actually affects
you now right no one affected me that
she [ __ ] I got busted hmm
I said I was so so so so sorry you a
[ __ ] about to my kid about me then yeah
but now oh now that that scream my
friends tell me I'm a bad [ __ ] - hmm
you know mmm my friends my [ __ ] they
tell me I'm a bad
negative right the ego yeah Wow yeah
when you ain't said a word
yeah but that's what they think - you
can't you can't tell something like
what's going on in their head you can't
tell somebody head mm-hmm you don't
think you could fully understand your
father until your own kid is yelling at
you I would love to spend a day in my
Texans brain oh man it would be I think
I made anyway I don't fight you don't
say that about yourself now you're bad
man you're good man Mike that's not true
you loving your then you know you
weren't unlike you when you did that
it's like that going on but I'm sorry
Mike that's where all my life is gonna
[ __ ] sorry he's come from them sorry
it's from the diamond I'm sorry please
forgive me God I'm sorry I don't mean to
do that
can I give them money you think get the
family money I we think are they [ __ ]
gonna say get the [ __ ] away from me I
want to buy myself in heaven sometimes I
was gonna give people money I'd make
money and I wish I can give it to
somebody that I heard before vark is not
really your responsibility on how people
forgive you yeah it's kind of I know
that's true no I know but I'm just
dealing with it how do you deal with
that
it's been done and you did it you bought
her for life because of you you people
affect the favor feel right because of
yourself even to yourself is you had to
do it even even money but you have to do
it
oh there opee
yeah therapy dude wait you wanna hurt
somebody in one item I just wanna see
them suffer
well on that idea of being a chosen one
whatever that means I think what that
translates to is that you're a person
willing to fully Express the [ __ ] that's
going on in here out here
you know I think a lot of people are
really afraid and terrified of being
themselves absolutely yeah
seen as having any joy because nobody
feels like they deserve to feel worthy
or happy think it's a thing that's
there's this thing in our culture where
it's not really cool to be happy it's
not cool to be a positive person like
it's a cooler thing to be negative yeah
and that's all of that those are the
Sheep you know those are the people who
are going about the [ __ ] nine-to-five
miserable depressed popping the pills
that their doctors prescribed going to
the job that they hate because they
think that makes them [ __ ] people
maybe Joe then I see some people that do
that and they're happiest most positive
people who earn their happiness they may
go like this I can get you a job at the
[ __ ] I'm the farm yeah at the [ __ ]
factory or something they it's positive
we really can't put our fingers on
people and why this and that because
then you see another person and they say
[ __ ] life is beautiful I love the
[ __ ] factory that I work in at
absolutely that's a different mindset
don't get you a job - mike is so good
they got pulled there to have a whole
life there right well what I'm saying is
it's the people who you know whatever
column the chosen ones column you know
the leaders of art of the tribe called
humanity you know you're [ __ ] putting
this [ __ ] is all spirit anyway it's all
coming from the universe and coming from
the cosmos and that's all being
expressed out of you and through you
Mandy not conscious wouldn't and what
most people are in but when you're not
conscious of that stuff it only works
for a certain amount
and stops working I don't think so you
know I think you have to be a great
being grips with yeah into it you should
let it go and think it's gonna get
stated forever without working on things
about it concentrate with it oh yes you
know yeah I grew that I think people see
negativity spreads so much faster than
negatively cook comes across so positive
yeah it's for you know means that says
it feels good to be negative it feels
good to fight yeah that's what we will
be for more than we [ __ ] in history
hmm can you imagine that sometimes we
[ __ ] we fought the [ __ ] [ __ ] them it's
just um we did that more than [ __ ]
this I need to the fight but it's not
we're not structured for fighting my
hand I feed that L we're not it's not
built for fighting mm-hmm they break
easy you know kinda hits on my Twitter
fits break or damage your hand so we're
not me for fighting but still we fight
we have fighting spirit and you can't
stop it even though we're gonna hurt
ourselves we fight yeah it's timeles
that brain I guess you know stimuli
separating like Joe what was it for you
that you had to step away from rattling
uh I don't think it was one thing in
particular well there was it say you
want you know I can't do this anymore
I put out an album in 2000 when it all
of lost my 2014 mmm
I didn't want to do it anymore when I
was actively doing it mm-hmm I didn't
come on we released Apple it was
redundant and boring did he get the
response that you wanted no it not
response it didn't get the result that
you and that meant that I wanted because
I was saving money this little Wayne
yeah he was on that he was an animal but
that that happened that was a listen it
save your life time it's not really
about the label gonna be mad you only
gonna do 20,000 or like they won't be
but i'ma be alive and that was my last
album on that particular label from that
point on it was about how do I stop this
hmm I don't three four months and to
creating a project tack on another two
to three months if you want to tour it
tack on another did you try our app yeah
I do
the worst on my life miserable
because that album was such a dark album
for me that by the time I went on tour I
was no longer feeling that way yet I had
to perform those records it was a
constant reminder it come it always
brought me back that's so interesting
yeah you know if I go on stage right
this is my ego if I gonna say [ __ ] my
life is happy my life my dick is hard I
people are applauding me and looking at
me and [ __ ] and why do I feel that way
you know I don't like the fact that like
that I feel that way mmm that makes
sense
yeah 100% also rappers wasn't getting
paid like the streaming these streaming
services ain't really they're not doing
the right thing just yet
and got a long way to let ecosystem is
structured properly if I was a good
rapper I would just do home parties I
would just go to people houses hey I
won't perform at your house before uncle
rich guy misses and that's what I was I
take a banner fair like I did Frankie
Beverly made I said performer my house
for my 30th birthday party
so I had them before so that's what I do
so when I throw parties that's the
parties will entertain a little bit like
wrap your fingers or something yeah I
love how you just said that so casually
yeah you're perfect Frankie Beverly and
maze
do what you do in that life that we all
make money we all do this thing we all
want to do something big we all want
somebody to remember some of us about
this party or something that's our ego
too I guess
and you know that's why we did it that's
what we do you know we can't even help
it that we do that we don't even like
the fact that our ego is talking to do
it but we don't have no control over it
so we do it
it tells us how good we're gonna feel
that that how [ __ ] special I mean
[ __ ] are gonna love with Thai many
people gonna notice an industry and yet
they're never gonna stop talking about
you and then I love you like you love
yourself
that's what's above ya are crazy
breakdowns [ __ ] you're dead you're
just like going on the ride with it
because no loans what he's seen and we
accomplished what he's been through and
the things that he's done so to hear it
coming from his mind it's like wow
because these are a lot of things that
I'm like yeah I want to experience that
but for him is going through it and then
say that ain't about [ __ ] and no one's
my biggest thing when I use like go to
the record companies and stuff and I
always loved the girls in the [ __ ]
offices they were always fairly [ __ ]
sexy and smart looking at [ __ ] and
you're always [ __ ] awesome and [ __ ]
right so we think the girl in the
[ __ ] company offices and [ __ ] mmm and
always want the workers you want a bunch
of line looking black woman or Latino
women in the office just cut that [ __ ]
together at the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
suitcase their bags looking elegant in
the hood yeah no flat I was starting
that [ __ ] for sure yeah I took the black
away that team of minorities went to
that other level quick
they said I represent in the world then
without even knowing it
what else you got for us Evan come on
give it to us that something do you got
five years you guys been doing the pot
in February will be five years Wow oh
I'm [ __ ] - every [ __ ] day
pretty much you're basing your opinion
spreading your word out you have to you
have to build and design your life the
way you want it to operate mmm I didn't
want to go on tour
I really hate touring to be perfectly
honest do you want to be a businessman
you want to be important you let me
entrepreneur you let me be involved with
um finances yeah yeah yeah oh look all
the good stuff all the conversations
they would never have to me if my if my
priority was putting albums up my dick
they just would not happen I don't think
I would fighting my [ __ ] I can't even
getting out of my perspective out I'm
just selling I'm so into my own [ __ ]
head mmm I'm so glad listening I'm so
glad that ego was never really my
struggle oh man you must doesn't think
I'm telling you something right now
it wasn't you don't even know it mm-hmm
you can't even stop drinking I say you
go you can't stuff with the bottle down
you know that you didn't know that
come on just stop [ __ ] playing
[ __ ] game all the time
know what I'm saying what I'm saying is
I don't want to just air correct I don't
want to drink yes you do I don't want to
guess you are no I'm not get the drink
you drunk
let's [ __ ] some [ __ ] now mmm that's
your [ __ ] [ __ ] you just get that
money back from the negative beat us in
the [ __ ] studio let's check them
[ __ ] they owe us money
oh let's just start going on now no see
your ego nice was more exciting than any
time I was drunk and I had two [ __ ]
in the living room all came upstairs
everyone did
none of us from the rap industry nervous
for my where we came from in our
neighborhood where I thought we do is
talk [ __ ] and everything without half
and [ __ ] that's what we do is brag and
play the Dozen on people how can we not
have egos that's the all that's [ __ ]
and we don't even know how we got here
we were on top lady but it's looking at
us we babbles and we forgot we got it
how do I [ __ ] get here now I figured
who did I beat to get here hmm
to get here who did I beat really wasn't
my first fight wasn't my last with this
big bull fight got me here's where I'm
with your guys on this [ __ ] mic right
here all of them huh
all of it all of them in all of it maybe
so you probably even right but I always
think what got me here okay before I got
here I was trying to count with high all
the time I'm [ __ ] on cocaine I was
[ __ ] drinking all the time so how did
I go from near and I got here once that
uh that very thing mmm and then
realizing that was wrong to get here no
I want to go back over here and then I
guess I involved tonight um I guess I
hit rock bottom and I didn't want to go
any further I was afraid to go to that
other level the last lecture yeah I
didn't want to go there it was getting
scary sighs I submitted huh you know
it's a minute I've unlocked plenty of
rock bottom secret doors got a ways to
go
Wow it's insane so you guys do the
podcast live and you [ __ ] sell it out
yeah podcast what are you doing a
podcast on boys
smoking weed on the pod all yours for
all this I don't smoke on the pot
anymore you know not anymore
I don't smoke on the pot anymore but I
do smoke I don't drink yeah yeah and
you're vegan Oh pescetarian I'm funny
too you know sometimes it'd be like say
they're doing pigs or cows or something
to be a dead pig that can't even be dead
in the garbage for two or three days
then they throw it at them at other pig
and cow either me and chop them
[ __ ] episode them to us yeah
well we're being slowly poisoned I heard
this the other day from my wife because
our daughter went and had a playdate
with her friend and they had McDonald's
for lunch and it was the first time in
my daughter's life she's had McDonald's
seven and a half pretty [ __ ] pumped
it's pretty good did you know they got
impossible burger now with McDonald's
and stuff I know I know that's good I
mean that's a good step but you know
french fries at McDonald's in the UK
have three ingredients potatoes salt and
sugar patife wrench fries at McDonald's
in the US has over 20 ingredients over
20 and green I don't taste good in
English I don't do the French rather
than [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] right the
French fries in English like shrimp is
[ __ ]
look up in the sky at any point in LA
and I guarantee you see a [ __ ] jet
flying with a [ __ ] you know smoke
dream behind it what the [ __ ] are they
pumping didn't someone tell me then put
a jet fuel employ they're pumping
[ __ ] chemicals they're just lacing us
with chemicals let's see what this [ __ ]
does today wouldn't see when they do
that to it that wonder what they think
well now I gotta go and I gotta land the
plane now I gotta go into the chemicals
I wonder what do they ever say that
right
well it's compartmentalized yeah so the
guy flying the plane he's like yeah
whatever I'm just [ __ ] shootin some
[ __ ] out of this jet I'm flying
we always a job to do yeah yeah but
listen man this is what I always say
every time we have the deep conversation
and we worried about the world then I
fade it gotta take care of tomorrow yeah
listen you think people we might not be
here yeah that's that's the whole thing
don't wanna see guys don't wanna do it
listen it won't solve all the bugs and
the planet died the planet would die if
all the [ __ ] trees realize the plant
the bird died the elder there the plan
would die right if all the humans died
the [ __ ] planet would flourish can't
be better
you know flourish it would grow they
won't cut [ __ ] they won't kill [ __ ]
everything will grow we have more than
we can ever imagine
mmm okay that's what we do we hear the
killer as we kill the blank between us
and are we are cancers this is a giant
party win for my knees body and this
isn't weird cancers just trying to kill
us
he's trying to get us up the planets
trying to get us down with it we're
fighting them to the [ __ ] bitter end
we're polluting them with [ __ ]
putting bombs you opening it up and
getting all the oil out of here we're
getting the [ __ ] volcanoes pissed off
again [ __ ] what's that [ __ ] that
toxic gas blow like you're coming out
give us optimism
but that's just what we live in we live
in is are losing giving this opportunity
your [ __ ] you like estimate no no no
you believe everything is beautiful
that's what we all here but the world is
in up world we think we can destroy the
work on destroy so if I do not believe
that everything's beautiful I do not
believe that living is what we're doing
here I don't know that we don't start
living when we leave here I don't know
that's what I said I don't know that's
why I want to know are you operate from
this piece of I don't know
hmm I can you not be curious and know
something it make me believe I know
something
don't let me fit I'm gonna die I think
so man 100% I hope so
100% you know when I wonder when I took
the toll you know and then I didn't have
no parent I didn't remember my wife and
my kids everything I love didn't exist
that's all about me it was nothing that
was associated with it existed in my
mind at that moment hmm I didn't think
about my family my kid call [ __ ]
canal in the [ __ ] house
[ __ ] [ __ ] you son I need some reason a
morning for coffee stroking those young
you're living long that ain't it it's
something else some [ __ ] attested not
felt resist oh my god we just like never
know who's gonna stroll through yeah you
never know I like that
we just we asked on my trial basis
that's how this this world has been
doing since the beginning about trial
basis it works strangely this stuff I
did was try slavery in another
perspective where I keep remix and you
have to wear that biggest a the biggest
theater soul everywhere the biggest one
especially they make you love yourself
we hang out with you you know me it then
Leslie you might be the honorary white
people one day a thousand years from now
or something you know I mean you never
know you gotta get we have to prepare
these people
I think the elements is gonna wipe all
of these idiots out before racism before
we saw before we see what racism yields
I think it's gonna be a big snowstorm or
all the dams a break and everybody's
gonna drown and I'm gonna be up to beer
and my ghost corner saying I told you
[ __ ] right that's our ego to we're
not that fortunate enough to be around
within in the world you know I mean
something that you'll say we're gonna be
around when this [ __ ] all goes down we
won't ever you think the Chinese water
China the war alone it took 2,000 years
to be made
imagine living life what happened within
that 2,000 years I was born you were
born all that time your grandmother your
great-grandmother with blame I don't I I
don't I'm not sure that humans are part
of the earth evolution am I not it's not
sir for everything that you said earlier
about us when it all of humans die the
earth will flourish I'm not certain that
we're a part of that we weren't always
here yeah wasn't we weren't better but
the earth was better you know yeah no I
don't know what's next
they got dogs [ __ ] pigs they got they
taking this gene mixing it with that
gene they're doing all types of [ __ ]
charlie
[ __ ] [ __ ] dog I used to watch
films and stuff bestiality cuz I
couldn't believe him [ __ ] [ __ ]
on a pig pig [ __ ] a [ __ ] some [ __ ]
like that
my suckling pig dick of something you
see what the [ __ ] you know I mean and
this is what's out here
you know sometimes right I saw a horse
[ __ ] what I'm not bail to never watch
another my sex classes I know what
sexting really do sex kills us it's our
[ __ ] it's our [ __ ] dream it's the
BTS sure this person I love I want them
to love me that's why I want to [ __ ]
them and you want to [ __ ] for love
that's all they want you want the person
that loved them or the dog or the animal
or whatever it is all come from love
[ __ ] I think there's better ways to get
your dogs I love you it's funny it's
funny but it's what it is yeah you can't
deal with the reality of what it is it's
in your face but we want to be what
everyone likes this for you want to be a
part what everybody likes us what we
want to be like you want to be loved the
only be known for [ __ ] animal the
[ __ ] people who are not animals but
should be animals still people think
should be animals you want to live a
life without judgement I'll have that
ever gonna happen that's what we want
don't judge me I still love you but
don't judge me you don't even want
nobody loves you judging though cool
weird external of right that's the
essence of life but we turn it down so
he's not he's not one of us he [ __ ]
somebody that he shouldn't have [ __ ]
oh it's not cool the [ __ ] I live with
they're all a bunch of hypocrites that's
who we are it's just human beings that
we're all hypocrites all we can't help
it we can't even help it mmm oh well
this was amazing I think you can [ __ ]
rise above that man's about what
judgment can rise about rise above
criticism rise above the voice in your
head that accept all criticism
absolutely once you do that then that's
easier
except that once you do that it turns
and then I'm rubber you're glue whatever
you say to me whatever the [ __ ] thing
was but that's how that goes
they're gonna judge you I'd judge me
every day I give two [ __ ] you don't I'm
sitting here I guess your your
attachments to it you know what I mean
but as an individual but look at this is
just think right this is this instance
right right now right this man we gotta
put aside we got to pick a side gotta be
a side we got a pic you gotta be a side
we're gonna pick sides how do we pick
sides I wouldn't pick I first feel huh I
feel I feel I ain't pickin nobody side
but you gotta pay because we feel
compelled to pick a side maybe for my
signal maybe every situation I was gonna
lead to it might lead to violence that
might be the alienation and [ __ ] you
know I mean what anyway would have to
pick a fight with a bull yo you fight it
out and yes i'ma stay with what I
believe in these whoever wins while we
can't do that why are we such a we an
such a following culture well people
need to follow something I agree that
too except for the ones who don't
yeah you know I don't see how y'all can
even have this podcast without a bunch
of weed around no I came in out of hand
with on mushrooms one time I did this
and it was really awesome or good though
yeah shrooms are good have you done I
never did Oh
[Music]
they're in bistros I want to do it
though yeah I want to do it yeah they'll
be like [ __ ] ribs are changing
experience yeah I don't know if y'all
really want to do a pot on shrooms yeah
so happy one day I was just happy
hanging out in the [ __ ] press rooms
chillin yeah I want to do shrooms a mall
oh yeah there was a listing I want to do
you guys should first do it like out in
a forest or [ __ ] somewhere peaceful
where you cannot be around a lot of
people because it just turns up your
senses to a million I'm gonna be there
to watch and you know if you're around
too many people for the first time it
might be a really unpleasant yeah the
first time I did it was not everyone did
it so it became just a weird energy in
them yeah where it's like four of us are
on shrooms and you two are just kind of
in the corner yeah why are you here
because you realize that everything is
out here man
it's all [ __ ] out here all your
feelings there's nothing but your
feelings in the [ __ ] world and your
attachments to everything around you and
your relationships to everything you
know your thoughts that's all there is
no I'm a duck guy from time to time in
the past no I didn't get that vibe from
you
buckets definitely did for sure but I
loved it I loved you I loved watching
that love talking to you for real man
this is very much this was an honor for
me he said he's coming to talk to you
tomorrow
he's coming aboard yeah he said he's
coming tomorrow what are they doing live
nation at rock nation was well rock
nation is a management company and uh
they manage artists and they help brand
artists and things like that
athletes and you know Jay is controlling
all that over there you know just just
doing this thing but Biggs and Jay was
you know just friends growing up and you
know Rockefeller back in the days of
Dane and other things they did and now
Biggs is doing his own thing so no we
don't get electric music dance music
stuff we get ready to get involved with
them we got property in any property in
city yeah yeah yeah I was watching time
I was looking at thing why I want to
become a part of this woman cuz I looked
at it different looked at it were the
[ __ ] from a political perspective
that was power 250,000 people there man
250 people rolling down on New York on
[ __ ] Central Park or [ __ ]
somewhere in Washington State and
watching them bomb in Washington DC yeah
you know me yeah we got the right that
of a party there man such a message you
can control the message that you give
that's what everything about music
everything is political it all started
from political rapping you know they did
like the guy from the 1500 therefore
therefore what happened to the Queen I
saw her with that glue beggar last night
whatever it is you know that's what we
are we're like Vanguard's of the modern
age we telling the stories and that's
what life is all about telling stories
people make movie like a thousand years
ago 200 years from now people make
movies or for people's raps like it was
real
certainly who's a real life that you
really actually happened what they're
doing it which I've seen all the movies
yeah yeah yeah sure but they're gonna do
in the way that we never believed could
be done you know in the name of the fan
who's who's doing the Mike Tyson movie
who's the actor
hey listen right was it Jamie fine then
I look at my life is nothing for
different now I could take something
like Mike Tyson and the plus they're
taking a little take some like Mike
Tyson life and I can make an atom at um
cartoon cartoon and put it on show like
every week something that happened in my
face right as a kid this happened and it
starts some ten years old all the way to
what 52 like getting this business and
stuff and the EDM keep on going but look
how long you can go the movie can years
ago we have a movie with here's letter
play for the rest of all we have this
continue to go right yeah it's right my
story
this happened out of 13 over 10 I wasn't
spotted I was locked up here I would say
Iraq or whatever just play from that
perspective mmm more people seeing that
we can make more money ain't gonna miss
even really not what they used to be
yeah no you know hmm
I need a movie on Spofford oh yeah you
know spawn fit yeah minutes Buffett on
my life I'm the kid huh oh yeah that was
that was the place we wanted to stay out
of gnawing up here you heard about that
from khilafat yeah
that's closed down all right yeah all
right what you got well it's been [ __ ]
awesome having you guys here it is never
go in the studio again I could be an
offense I'm I see a bill job post
fitment spitting on wanna record and
nothing Mike we didn't have all this
great amazing talk for me to pretend I
know what tomorrow holds
loneliness you're creating an out people
songs and feel just fit man you still do
that right no ah man no yes finished huh
yeah you know it's like you said earlier
once you once you once you let go it all
came yeah you're right like the second I
stopped rapping there were vast
improvements all around my life mmm
dad they don't come for me to say all
right let me get back in my Joe bag and
do what Joe wants people are so strong I
can't imagine seeing you when I rap and
I thought was faithful just stupid
question and you know what's interesting
about that Mike what I learned yesterday
is it was never to wrap it it was always
me it was all the way back to that
chosen one thing all that power and all
the things that I was able to make
happen independently in music and that's
a lot if you understand a music that's a
lot the second I start wrapping those
things continued it was never the action
using one or two bars it's not it's all
an illusion like you say that's it's me
we decide to rap next year or in two
years with with a quick here's where I'm
at it'll be it'll be from a place of
what and that need it won't be because I
need to live it won't be because I need
to vent it won't be because I need a
dollar it won't be because I need
attention how do you feel about money I
could give a [ __ ] about it I can give I
think I only have some because I have
all never given a [ __ ] about it money
allows me to have shorter phone calls
with people that quote
yes go ahead okay go
how much got it for me I'm so low
maintenance might I don't need nothing
I've been homeless my [ __ ] like we
could really sit here and talk I don't
need much all this [ __ ] but God's grace
and mercy think it could all be gone
tomorrow today
we walk out of here and black people he
knows [ __ ] that we operate from that
fear of not one day's to go back to how
they they were so yeah that fear drives
me up it motivates me more I don't know
why going back the book and be going be
like money put the nice treat
[ __ ] still in the tree the
cameras the [ __ ] turn the
cameras man they still the light that
blow up that keep the luminate the place
with the crime they used to say traffic
like [ __ ] ago she a [ __ ] that kill
you they kill themselves l care man look
I still love them I'm proud to be from
there so probably be from there it's
awesome so I'm glad to hear you say that
like oh absolutely
I might even had a pair of lime-green
Karl Kani jeans [ __ ] on a baggy suit you
talking [ __ ] where you get some track
suits some hot box of track suits
yeah yeah door oh [ __ ] smiling I
never [ __ ] stop smiling I forget your
bidding I should bend this [ __ ] right
those wipe your hand
well you guys want to tell everybody
where they can find you out you still
talking to people on the internet though
right yeah
yeah you can definitely definitely find
us on Spotify twice a week every
Wednesday and Saturday you can find us
so no one in the award for you um
podcast yet you want it be social or
noise yeah don't do that don't matter
it's a form of improving yourself you've
never done this before now you got a
wolf or something you never dreamed of
doing before this is hey this is uh no
no no no it's not they not ain't not the
determiner of of when our improvement
occurs no no thank you for the
acknowledgement exactly everybody is we
all are we want you to succeed that's
why you know number one guy cuz they're
the fans we all want you to succeed off
my fighter our fight is so much bigger
than mm-hmm
thank thank you I'll get it out the way
it's a distraction okay you got a big
fight going on are you telling me you
tell me yeah but all this all the thin
though if anything's out here bothering
you it's because it's in with them if
you cool within that night about this is
nothing this is no losing this is the
[ __ ] physical wouldn't composure you
out here no [ __ ] you
this is no I'm mad at the discrepancy in
ad dollars between white people and
black people and this podcast game and
in some other games but we've been here
too long so I'm not gonna start there I
don't think that comes from hating me I
just think it comes from a good
understanding of what the [ __ ] is going
on in the ecosystem out online yes make
it better that's all don't complain but
we have to make it better I know what
[ __ ] thing Rory is here
all your skills I'm not a lawyer no no
I'm a Poli skate man and I podcast I
manage here and there wouldn't know I
hire lawyers laughs yeah I'm not a
lawyer things gonna happen with this
podcast man can't go any higher
absolutely I don't even think we've
scratched the surface of how big
podcasting is gonna get into the award
point you were making I think there
needs to be a proper award show that
really sure and in platforms like you
guys is just absolutely a world what
cathica they have it all over the world
it should be a world championship a
world festival whatever it is it's a
moral perspective I mean five years ago
it was way [ __ ] different pasta oh
yeah people barely knew at podcasts were
five years ago yeah and now it's I don't
know it was when I started one I didn't
know what that word meant hmm and a
second someone explained it to me I said
oh I just remember seeing the app and
being like the [ __ ] do I do it yes on an
iPhone it's not music what is this
that's how I discover my dick when I was
12
I'm gonna [ __ ] yeah hey we're gonna get
some food thank you guys so much thank
you welcome here anytime
thank you really appreciate and when we
will be back hey we did with the okay
last time you did a song with him he was
good yeah it was he doing all right
these days I wouldn't have spoken stays
yeah
hey miss wings off the hook - Mike
follow me badly Instagram that nothing
interesting button be [ __ ]
[Music]
I'll be back here this beautiful
establishment let me talk to you about
told we not offer that still my tracks I
want to tracksuit oh yeah we got one oh
yeah yeah yeah I'm jealous yeah it's
cool - all right way to cool down too
hot to it as [ __ ] he sure to subscribe
to our YouTube channel hot box
Tyson chicken our website hotbox a
podcast
[Music]